just walk me through what happened man
what sticks out to you about how you got
this game
uh we're just a resilient bunch
they hit us with Haymakers after
Haymaker at the Haymaker trying to get
us to fall
we just stayed in the fight we just
stayed in the fight you know uh it's a
48-minute game or if it's a 12 round
boxing match and we stayed in there for
12 rounds man and was able to pull it
through I'm gonna give you two names and
you tell me about this place
I see you engaged with him what did you
say to him and what did you think about
his performance not even about tonight
I've been telling him I said Lonnie stay
ready we're gonna need you at some point
and for him to be as young as he is for
him to have that that professionalism
come out stay ready when his number was
called
we don't win this game without Lonnie
Walker tonight that's for sure A.D
defensively on Steph tell me about that
ain't the best defensive player in the
league
I mean you know I think the league knows
it as well not many guys that can
protect the rim at all costs and also
switch out on point guards switch out on
guys like Steph Steph is a hell of a
player I had a hell of a game I think he
even had a triple double
but we trust ad guarding anybody in this
league and he showed that
one game away from closing this thing
out go back to Golden State what is it
going to take
I mean as hard as this game was it's
gonna be even harder
we understand that we know that and if
we don't come in with a desperate
mindset like they're going to come in
then they're going to blow us out
they're going to blow us out that Arena
so
we've been in a 3-1 situation in round
one first Memphis so we got we got to
learn from that when we're not saying
that Memphis is Golden State both teams
are well coached both teams are great
but we also know we're dealing with the
defendant Champion so
I mean it's time to get rest now tired
as hell man get out my face Take Care
thank you guys that's a good way to end
the interview LeBron James excellent
night tonight 27 points nine rebounds
six assists it was Lonnie Walker the 24
year old out of Miami with the 15 Point
fourth quarter thanks to Tom high top
producer director Andrew